there are an estimated this many
individual viruses on earth luckily
there are only a little over a thousand
virus strains known to infect humans the
majority of which come from other
animals they're part of a group called
zoonotic diseases caused by bacteria
viruses parasites or fungi and the one
we're all focusing on now is the virus
that causes kovat 19:00 and new ones can
emerge at any time here's what needs to
happen for a virus to jump from animals
to humans as a pathogen the virus's goal
is to infect its host and replicate
because it can't do that on its own
let's say this pig is the original host
of a virus he and his buddies form a
reservoir a specific population of
animals of the same species that
naturally hosts a pathogen so the
romanians of virus is out there
infecting animals we find do most of
those viruses don't infect you know
other animals they have a restricted
host range most of the time the virus
doesn't affect its original hosts or
only mildly affects it so what's it
doing in there suppose that this pig
host virus that primarily infects the
gut viruses tend to attack different
parts of the body depending on whether
they can bind to these guys receptors
are proteins found along the outside of
a cell used to communicate with the rest
of the body but viruses can latch on to
cells and a respiratory system may have
different receptors than cells in a
digestive tract a virus does its thing
by latching on to a host cell entering
it or injecting bits of itself into it
and then hijacking it it forces the cell
to make copies of the virus all of which
will go on to hijack other host cells
this will usually kill the host cell and
if enough of the host cells are infected
and make more of the virus the host will
contract an infection which if the body
can't fight it off or fights too hard
could lead to severe disease or death in
reservoirs however
the species has likely evolved a
resistance to the virus over many
generations this allows the sort of
equilibrium the immune system controls
the infection without killing the virus
off completely if the virus jumps though
a new host won't have that same or any
immunity that might sound scary because
truthfully you are constantly being
exposed to viruses but only a very small
number succeed at infecting a new host
species it's called spillover and there
are a series of barriers that a virus
must navigate for that to happen if it's
held up by even one of these it can be
stopped in its tracks simplified they
represent two things can the virus get
to the new host cells and can it bind
and enter them the more infected pigs
there are in one space and the closer
they are to people generally the more
chance of spillover but the likelihood
also has to do with how the humans are
interacting with them animal viruses are
usually transmitted to people in a few
ways contact with excretions slaughter
bites contact with tissues or through an
intermediate species like mosquitoes or
ticks so places like farms and
slaughterhouses and even petting zoos
where people come in close contact with
animals of an increased risk of
spillover proximity alone isn't enough
though some of it can be genetic for
humans there's a huge list of genes that
have been associated with different
risks of infections seven genes offering
resistance to certain infections and
others increasing risk beyond genes the
virus has to get through the body's
innate immune responses the so called
adaptive immune responses so those are
antibodies and T cells and they
generally get stimulated after the
infection has already occurred the
innate responses are the ones that are
already presidents at the cell that make
an SLE or a hose you know resistant to
the virus unlike an adaptive response an
innate one can attempt to fight off any
pathogen rather than a specific one
mucous membranes stomach acid skin scent
and even just a lack of the right
receptors can stop a virus from
infecting a person so this is when
mutations are really important
a successful spillover usually doesn't
happen with the original virus we have
to gain some mutations that allow them
to replicate most efficiently allow them
to overcome those barriers a virus that
infects the digestive system of the pig
might attack respiratory cells in humans
it depends on what receptor the virus is
suited for or mutates to be suited for
once inside the new host cell an
infection will only be successful if the
virus can replicate typically infected
cells will release interferons proteins
that stop the virus from replicating
within the cell and in nearby cells
which contain the infection and stop it
from spreading to new cells if that
doesn't work the adaptive immune system
kicks in your t-cells suss out and kill
already infected cells to stop them from
making more new virus while your white
blood cells pump out antibody is
specifically tailored to fight this new
pathogen but because the body has never
seen this virus before it can take weeks
to produce the right ones and
immunodeficiency is in either type of
response can make it even easier for a
virus to take hold so if a virus gets
through all that contact infection
replication then it has successfully
spilled over but the virus has to be
able to transmit it has to be able to be
shed from that original person and it
has to be able to infect you know at
least one or two more additional people
so that you can start a chain of
transmission a virus infecting two
people has doubled the odds of going on
to infect additional people compared to
a virus infecting just one and this can
continue until it reaches epidemic and
pandemic proportions Koba 19 was
certainly not the first zoonotic disease
and it won't be the last
viruses don't want to kill their hosts
no host means no virus but new diseases
are so dangerous because humans don't
have the same immunity as the viruses
reservoir hosts and because there are so
many
it's currently not possible to predict
when or what specific viruses will spill
over but we do know the conditions in
which spillover can occur you know how
and where they might occur and how we
can put in place sort of better
monitoring so that we can catch them
early and as they say steppin out before
they get to the point where they become
sort of an out-of-control epidemic
[Music]
[Music]